sur cette vidéo la voiture d'un homme se
retrouve coincé au milieu d'un cortège
en marge d'un mariage qui devait être
célébré à Épinay-sur-Seine
l'automobiliste aurait voulu circuler
dans une rue bloquée par le cortège qui
célèbre l'événement avec des feux
d'artifice et des rodéo urbains mais la
tension monte rapidement plusieurs
individus sortent alors de leur véhicule
et s'en prennent à l'automobiliste il
lui a scène des coups de poing et des
coups de pied sous les yeux de sa fille
de 5 ans restée dans la voiture la
victime blessée à la tête et à l'abdomen
a été transportée à l'hôpital avant de
déposer plainte mais au vu des
circonstances le maire a préféré annuler
la cérémonie de peur que les
débordements ne se propagent au-delà de
la ville
merci à ridwan et Ryan d'être avec nous
alors qui est
ridoine très bien vous êtes le frère et
le cousin du marié qui est le frère et
moi d'accord et vous êtes le cousin très
bien et on a Réda Bella j'importe parole
et GP police merci de venir nous voir
encore un Reda c'est toujours un bonheur
alors qu'est-ce qui s'est passé riedawan
et Ryan qui veut prendre
Redouane vas-y c'est mon cousin parce
qu'il était devant ok donc c'est vrai
que la vidéo elle a tourné toute la
journée tout le monde s'est demandé
c'est un extrait de la vidéo d'accord
donc ça c'est un extrait qui a été bien
pris voilà le moment était bien choisi
ce qui est présenté c'est bien choisi
on voit pas déjà ce qui s'est passé
avant et une enquête qui est en cours
on dit qu'il y a un automobiliste qui
très simplement c'est parti d'une
embrouille on va dire entre un atomes
et un autre automobiliste
une brouille qui aurait pu arriver à
n'importe qui tout le temps sauf que
ensuite d'un côté il y en a un qui a
aussi chercher l'autre parce que ce
qu'on entend dans les médias en ce
moment c'est que c'est gratuit d'accord
c'est comme si on avait pris quelqu'un
dehors et qu'on s'est arrêté qu'on avait
tabassé c'est pas du tout ce qui s'est
passé parce que là-bas une brouille
sur une personne
on en parlera après on en parle un peu
des gens on a 15 sur une personne il y a
des gens qui séparent dans ces images là
et il y a des gens qui sont en train de
taper et ça c'est pas c'est pas les 15
en train de taper une seule et même
personne je suis à côté je vois la scène
de mes propres yeux d'accord d'accord
alors
le chauffeur en question
n'était pas content en fait du fait
qu'on va y laisser passer les voitures
du cortège parce qu'on était
effectivement en train de bloquer pour
que les voitures du cortège puissent se
former on venait de partir on habite à
deux minutes d'accord donc on était en
train de former le cortège sur ce
cortège en formation donc il y a une
première voiture qui est qui s'est mise
pour bloquer et des deux personnes donc
en scooter qui venait aussi bloquer pour
que les autres voitures puissent former
le cortège donc certes alors je suis
d'accord avec vous vous allez dire on
n'a pas faire ça sur la route etc bon ça
c'est pas le débat là mais sur sur les
faits le l'individu qui n'était pas
content à essayer de shooter un des gens
du cortège c'est ce qui s'est passé
celui qui en moto et il est en fait on
essaie le shooter de lui shooter sa
jambe c'est parti de là en fait et là
donc les deux personnes se sont donc un
peu embrouillées il y a eu un coup qui
est parti la personne est remontée dans
sa voiture on lui a demandé de s'en
aller donc on l'a dit va-t'en c'est bon
repas à ce moment-là qu'est-ce qu'il a
fait en fait avec sa voiture il a
enclenché une première et il a tapé
volontairement un véhicule du cortège
d'accord lui il avait un Clio II il a
tapé la voiture qu'on voit là la voiture
blanche à Cannes il voilà il a tapé
c'est un Cayenne S ah pardon il l'a tapé
directement en fait dans l'arrière il a
éclaté le pare-choc arrière d'accord et
voyez le Clio donc il a tapé le
pare-choc à ce moment là il faut savoir
qu'il y a des gens qui quand même payent
des cautions enfin vous voyez je sais
pas je mets à la place de quelqu'un qui
a payé une caution qui a son véhicule
qui peut-être à galérer à le payer je
sais pas au moment où ça nous arrive on
est tous humains et c'est une réaction à
son show que la personne a ils sont
peut-être plusieurs à avoir pris la
voiture en question à ce moment-là quand
l'autre le tape effectivement alors
qu'il avait déjà été prévenu qu'on lui
avait déjà demandé de s'en aller il tape
et il dit cher en gros c'est ça qui
s'est passé c'est que la personne en
fait elle a été contente elle a dit
tiens en gros c'est ce qui s'est passé
et à ce moment-là c'est reparti un peu
en cacahuète il y a des gens qui
venaient donc derrière il y en a qui
sont même pas au courant ce qui se passe
devant derrière on voit même pas moi en
l'occurrence j'arrive de derrière mais
la pollution d'après la voiture tu m'as
rien n'est même pas encore là la voiture
de mariée on va parler parce que le mari
il est même pas concerné par cette
affaire là d'ailleurs mais ça on va en
parler après parce que je pense que
c'est le débat aussi bien sûr ce qui se
passe en fait là à ce moment là c'est
qu'il y a des gens qui viennent séparer
regardez il y en a qui tapent certes
mais il y en a d'autres qui sont en
train d'essayer d'empêcher sauf qu'on
peut pas contrôler tout le monde à ce
moment-là quand il y a quelqu'un qui met
un coup ou un autre qui met un coup nous
on peut pas être là en train de dire toi
tu as pas on n'est pas non plus son
regardez ce qui s'est passé à la mairie
après pour contrôler les 70 personnes
qui étaient là ils ont appelé quand même
au moins 50 policiers donc c'est bien
pour contrôler des gens on a besoin du
même nombre d'effectifs en face
sur le coup il y a des gens qui séparent
des gens qui séparent pas d'autres qui
s'aperçoivent qu'effectivement
l'automobiliste était avec sa fille donc
ça gêne encore plus de monde du fait
qu'il soit avec sa fille de le frapper
devant sa fille donc il y a des gens qui
disent arrêter il y a sa fille mais je
suis dedans donc je le sais arrêtez
arrêtez on est en train d'essayer de
vraiment de se enfin de faire en sorte
que ça se passe bien ou à la base c'est
pas c'est pas le but le mariage le but
c'est pas d'aller frapper quelqu'un mais
en gros depuis qu'on en parle on dirait
que ça a été fait gratuitement comme
s'il y avait aucune raison il y a quand
même raison il y a un automobiliste qui
a cherché jeune cautionne pas la
violence attention je ne dis pas qu'il
aurait fallu que ça arrive là le
meilleur moyen c'est le la meilleure
solution ça aurait été pas d'hôpital pas
de police c'est le nous c'est ça le but
on est là pour fêter on est là pour
célébrer on n'est pas là pour que ça en
arrive à là qu'il y ait des échauffourés
etc pour le coup de quand vous voyez ça
les images je vous interdis de dire
qu'on est 15 à taper une personne je
suis dedans je suis moi-même en train
d'essai de séparer je me suis moi-même
pris un coup en essayant de séparer donc
forcément c'est vous laisserez pas dire
qu'on est 15 sur une seule et même
personne ça je peux pas vous laisser le
dire maintenant il y a des gens faut
savoir que c'est un effet de groupe six
mois il m'arrive quelque chose et que
mon pote à il m'a fait ça forcément ça
peut aller vite ça mais ça peut arriver
à n'importe qui là en estimant
stigmatisé comme des racailles des
voyous parce que ça arrive et que bah
effectivement on voit des noirs et des
Arabes la plupart du temps ben voilà
donc c'est des noirs et des Arabes de
citer ils sont en train de faire un
cortège ça se passe mal comme si on
l'avait cherché nous c'est pas ce qu'on
cherchait on a nos en aucun cas on s'est
dit qu'on allait faire ce cortège là et
que ça allait se passer comme ça en
aucun cas on s'est dit qu'on allait
faire un cortège et que ça allait partir
en échauffouré ou autre en aucun cas
c'est pas le but rien c'est c'est la
même version que que
franchement je le maire il dit non pour
célébrer le mariage c'est je trouve ça
inadmissible parce que il a à peine 22
ans une personne que vous voyez là vous
avez minimum âgé de 26 ans vous voyez
mon petit frère sorti et dire à tout le
monde ouais non attendez attendez même
les personnes qui vont le regarder les
gens du mal son petit frère qui se marie
hein je le rappelle et ça et donc ils
ont refusé de célébrer le mariage exact
en sachant que la mariée n'était même
pas encore dans le cortège on allait la
chercher donc qui est arrivé à la mairie
qu'on lui dise ah non il y a un problème
en fait le plus beau jour de leur vie si
vous voulez ce qui se passe là c'est
quoi c'est que le marié il a un
chauffeur lui d'accord le marié il est
censé être en tête de cortège avec un
chauffeur donc il y a déjà une première
partie le chauffeur lui il calcule pas
un peu le cortège c'est la aux autres de
suivre un peu le chauffeur donc lui il
est même pas là au moment des faits il
est déjà beaucoup plus long il sait même
pas ce qui est en train de se passer et
plus loin et on nous parle de la Charte
on a entendu comme quoi ils avaient
signé une charte comme quoi c'est du
coup c'est leur responsabilité ou autre
pour le coup il est même pas là la
mariée la mariée quand on arrive chez la
mariée faut savoir que la mariée elle
est même pas au courant mais même le
mari n'est pas au courant la mère de la
mariée on arrive à la mairie et c'est là
où tous les policiers arrivent et où les
gens qui demandent ce qui se passe et là
où les gens commencent à parler un peu
ce qui s'est passé alors justement Reda
Bella tu peux pas les GP police pour
vous qu'est-ce qui s'est passé c'est la
même version que vous avez alors moi
malheureusement j'ai la version de la
victime parce que je pense qu'il faut
pas le monsieur a raison on n'a pas tout
filmé il parle pas des mortiers qui ont
été lancés sur la voie publique pendant
le le déroulement du cortège et vous
avez une victime
dans pendant ce mariage je pense que
c'est établi quand même elle a un enfant
de 5 ans dans son véhicule
d'après les premières premiers éléments
de l'enquête on sait que elle voulait
juste passer à gauche ou à droite et il
y a un premier véhicule qui n'a pas
laissé passer elle a trouvé un petit
passage elle est passée il y a un
deuxième véhicule du cortège issu du
cortège qu'il a doublé qui a bloqué la
route à l'individu un individu est sorti
du véhicule et là du coup c'est pas la
même version que Monsieur il est sorti
du véhicule il a frappé à la fenêtre du
du monsieur il lui a dit sors je vais te
casser la gueule déjà c'est pas du tout
la même version et derrière le gars il a
eu très très peur il a il a dit qu'il
avait sa fille apparemment d'habitude il
se laisse pas faire mais là quand il est
sa fille il a décidé de rien faire et le
gars insisté et le gars sans faire
exprès la victime a relâché le frein et
à percuter le véhicule donc c'était pas
du tout excusez-moi monsieur laissez-moi
finir moi je suis pas c'est pas moi
j'étais pas sur place vous rencontrer
un frein que ça part je sais pas c'est
un Clio II c'est pas annuel il faut pas
non mais qu'on soit d'accord
manuel elle dit qu'elle allait chez
Franck la voiture excusez-moi je
comprends pas vous verrez quand vous
aurez des enfants si vous êtes avec
votre enfant de 5 ans à l'arrière et qui
a un gars qui vient qui pète votre
fenêtre avec des jeunes mortiers je sais
pas peut-être qu'il devait aller chez le
médecin avec sa fille mais c'est normal
on a le droit de couper la route
d'ailleurs pour vous c'est normal mais
normalement il reste il existe des
règles d'accord on peut pas interdire
nous les pollutions on a le droit mais
on n'a pas le droit d'empêcher les gens
d'aller venir dans la société normale on
peut encore et c'est pas parce qu'on a
épiné sur scène qu'on peut le faire
c'est le débat voilà non mais c'est pas
c'est pas parce que vous dites c'est pas
le débat mais si si vous avez si le
monsieur excusez-moi laissez-moi finir
si le monsieur avait pas coupé la route
oui il y aura pas de problème d'accord
et aujourd'hui on a une victime qui
s'est fait un peu enfin qui s'est fait
bah écoutez elle est très très choquée
je pense que la fille même si elle a 5
ans je pense qu'elle va s'en rappeler je
pense que la femme voilà moi après en ce
qui concerne le sujet du maire moi je
suis pas représentant de la mairie s'il
y a des décisions qui peuvent être
prises pour éviter à l'avenir ce genre
de choses je pense qu'il faut les
prendre moi mes collègues ils sont
arrivés mais la petite 5 ans qui a dû
voir son père
violence c'est-à-dire que même si des
circonstances selon votre version qui
est très structurée peuvent expliquer on
ne peut pas cautionner l'acte de
violence à ça on est tous d'accord voilà
après moi ce qui me gêne ce sont les
suites c'est à dire que ça c'est du de
la violence sur la voie publique la
police intervient les gens sont
interpellés d'accord bien sûr il a
interpellé
à la maison moi ce qui me gêne Cyril
c'est la décision du maire mais non de
ne pas marier
nous à la base on voulait parler de ça
des circonstances le maire a préféré
annuler la cérémonie de peur que les
débordements ne se propagent au-delà de
la ville c'est vraiment la première fois
qu'il y a une violence telle qui a été
déchaînée contre une personne qui était
pour rien qui était qui s'est trouvé au
mauvais moment lors du passage de ce
cortège et ça c'est une admissible et
c'est inacceptable alors vous Valérie
sur la commune déjà il y avait une
charte de bonne conduite que le maire
avait pris j'allais dire presque en
prévision de d'éventuelles débordements
de tous les mariages qui peuvent se
produire cette charte de bonne conduite
elle est pas respectée donc on connaît
on connaît derrière les décisions qui
qui en écoutent là en l'occurrence le
maire qui est responsable de la sécurité
de ce qui se passe pour sa commune se
dit ce mariage ne peut pas se dérouler
dans les meilleures conditions parce que
les gens mes administrés on risque des
problèmes et bien fait moi je pense
qu'il a bien fait parce que évidemment
derrière ça aurait pu dégénérer parce
que les parce que les esprits étaient
très courts je vais vous expliquer une
chose quand on est arrivé à la mairie
les aujourd'hui on interpellé une fois
nous arrivés à la mairie moi et ma
famille nous sommes partis voir le maire
nous avons demandé au maire
tous nos amis tous nos tous les invités
part
ent il reste que moi mon petit frère la
mariée et le maire en petit comité bien
sûr on lui a demandé voilà et même comme
je vous ai dit dans le cortège mon petit
frère n'était pas encore arrivé au
problème même lui n'était pas au courant
sur la route on lui a demandé de faire
une bonne fois que mon petit frère ok
d'accord on concerne pas la violence qui
a été faite mais vous voyez un petit de
22 ans sortir au milieu de tout ça et
dire ah non arrêtez même les personnes
qui sont là sur le coup de l'énervement
ils vont jamais d'écouter ou quoi c'est
pas de pénaliser le tickets essentiels
le plus beau jour de sa vie Redouane
juste pour revenir sur l'achat parce que
vous parlez de la charte vous savez
comment elle a été signée cette charte
d'accord c'est la Marie qui l'assignée
de marine n'était même pas là ok c'est
pas le meilleur qu'il a fait signer
c'est un assistant jimmer qu'il a fait
signer d'accord non non
on devrait même pas avoir à la suite
je vais y venir justement je vais y
venir cette chartre là elle a été signée
par la mariée déjà palmier le marié
limite il n'est même pas au courant sa
chatte là cette charte là excusez-moi
parce que si on l'assume pas le mariage
n'a pas lieu d'accord quand je vous
ramène un contrat maintenant est-ce que
vous lisez tout le contrat avant de
signer tout le temps si j'avais alors ça
dépend chez moi oui c'est quoi ce que je
veux dire c'est quoi c'est que des fois
on signe des papiers nous-mêmes parce
que c'est des formalités on a inventé il
a 21 ans c'est en 2001 là ça m'arrive
c'est une 2002 c'est c'est des jeunes à
qui on va parler administratif à qui on
va leur présenter un papier même
attendez je vais non mais je vais vous
le dire je vais venir parce que vous me
dit ça m'intéresse je vais venir je vais
venir donc on parle de cette charte
parce qu'on a justifié en fait les actes
par rapport à cette charte ils ont signé
donc le mariage n'a pas lieu car ils
n'ont pas respecté la charte c'est ça en
fait qui se passe parce que si cette
charte n'est pas signé en quoi le
mariage n'aurait pas lu en quoi ils sont
responsable ils sont responsables par
rapport à la chaîne ils ont signé c'est
ce qu'on est c'est ce qu'on entend nous
dans les médias ils ont signé une charte
ils ont on parle que de la Charte là
maintenant il y a pas eu de
sensibilisation la charte excusez-moi
on a compris il y a pas eu de
sensibilisation en fait par rapport à
cette charte là on n'a pas demandé à
signer on n'a pas insisté sur les points
par exemple c'est du bon sens je vais
venir je vais venir bien sûr que c'est
du bon sens et c'est là où justement on
en vient comme Monsieur Gilbert Luigi à
ne pas justement à faire en pâtir les
mariés parce que c'est du bon sens c'est
propre à chacun chacun normalement doit
sur la route être maître de ce qu'il
fait on n'a pas besoin d'une charte ou
que les mariés viennent demander à ce
que ce soit respecté c'est le propre à
chacun si moi demain je suis policier
est-ce que mon ami qui va faire une
bêtise je vais te juger pour lui parce
que je suis policier que je l'ai pas
prévenu c'est c'est pas c'est pas
logique en fait lui en l'occurrence il
vient il vient par rapport à par rapport
aux mariés etc il peut lui de l'autre
c'est 21 ans aller venir voir des
invités de 25 30 ans et tous faire un
rappel faire le moralisateur avec on va
on vous pose la question chez vous
est-ce que le maire a bien fait pour
vous de d'annuler le mariage ou est-ce
qu'il est temps est-ce qu'il a bien fait
ou pas dites-nous Géraldine maillet non
mais moi je vous entends vous êtes
d'accord pour dire que le mariage
normalement c'est quelque chose de Gai
de festif d'apaisé alors là ça se
transforme en octogone déjà à quel
moment on a des mortiers pour aller à un
mariage alors je vous expliquez dites
moi des fleurs
si vous connaissez pas ça arrive dans
pratiquement tous les mariages tout le
temps
non mais
dans beaucoup de marées ça se passe
comme ça
il y a des cultures qui voilà ont envie
de je sais pas de faire un peu la fête
il y a personne qui a été visée par les
mortiers on a pas c'est pas les mortiers
tirés sur les policiers c'est pas des
mortiers tirer sur des passants c'est
pas des mortiers en l'occurrence c'est
pas des mortiers pour pour être violent
on cherche pas la violence si vous
demain vous avez un dette avec un homme
qui vous pourriez bien longtemps qu'il y
a plus de détails
ça fait plaisir parce que on était dans
notre dans le dans le quartier où on
habite on a des droits et des devoirs
la question est-ce que le maire a-t-il
bien je trouve que dans ce contexte oui
parce qu'on a des droits et des devoirs
et malgré tout je trouve que là c'était
pas du tout apaisé que beaucoup trop
compliqué et je trouve qu'il y a le vous
payez aussi le nombre de mariages qui
ont dérapés exactement le maire il nous
a pris exemple tout simplement le maire
nous a pris comme exemple et voilà
exactement comme je diraismond et malgré
tout voilà ça n'est pas possible donc
oui dans un premier temps il faut
l'annuler et puis revenir un peu plus
tard voilà et en quoi des gens des
mariés sont responsables de ce qui se
passe loin d'eux de voie de fait de
violence sur la voie publique ça n'a
aucun rapport elle est où la mariée
ou bien le mariage
on se marie et ben on y est responsable
et donc tout le monde doit donc moi je
suis responsable de
vous inviter des invités mais moi je
suis tombé nous sommes pas là à ce
moment-là
bien sûr que ça c'est j'aurais pu éviter
ça Mathieu Delormeau pour vous il a eu
raison Emmanuel mariage j'entends ce que
vous dites les gars je remets pas en
cause votre votre bonne foi et c'est
peut-être lui qui a attaqué le premier
peu importe la réalité c'est que
aujourd'hui le mariage il aime deux et
pardon vous le dire mais les
responsables c'est vous pourquoi et
c'est pas les autres arrêtez d'essayer
de trouver des des des raisons des
machins c'est vous pourquoi vous étiez
un cortège je sais pas quoi 10 12
voitures ça veut dire que vous êtes
responsable quand même le gars arrêt
tord vous êtes responsable vous êtes un
effet de masse vous passez au milieu des
gens vous dérangez les gens avec le
cortège comme ça déjà été fait une
première fois parfois en tirant du
brûlure klaxonnant vous avez un cortège
vous êtes responsable vous êtes un
groupe un groupe de une masse et ça veut
dire que vous savez très bien que si
jamais ça dérape il va y avoir cette
espèce de phénomène de masse ce qui
s'est passé là donc c'était à vous de
tenir ce cortège et quand bien même le
gars vous agresse c'est quand même le
gars le premier à vous à vous insulter
vous calmer les choses c'était à vous de
gérer ça vous n'avez pas géré
aujourd'hui vos amis ne sont pas mariés
et pourquoi à cause de vous et
uniquement à cause de ce cortège qui a
dérapé parce que vous n'avez pas su le
tenir et je suis désolé c'est pas la
première fois qu'on voit ça et
effectivement un mariage ça doit pas
être fait comme ça on doit pas déranger
les concitoyens on doit pas déranger les
gens dans la rue on doit pas tirant on
doit pas tirer des trucs que je sais pas
quoi et non alors j'entends n'est pas
d'accord avec vous non je pense qu'on
est dans un jugement trop hâtif en fait
cette vidéo on l'a tous vu effectivement
sur les réseaux sociaux ça dure 15
secondes c'est pixelisé moi quand je
l'ai vu effectivement j'ai cru qu'il y
avait les mariés dans la vidéo j'ai cru
qu'avec 15 personnes qui s'acharnaient
sur une personne j'ai cru tout ça en
fait effectivement les sorties de son
contexte et quand on a les explications
de de Monsieur de Monsieur bah on
comprend que c'est un peu plus complexe
que ça et pour moi les mariés sont des
victimes collatérales dans cette
histoire ils ne sont même pas dans la
scène pourquoi on doit les pénaliser
qu'on pénaliser parce que ce sont leurs
amis non mais responsable de ses amis
sont cortège et même des gens qui
arrivent tout seul tous ses amis tout ce
que font tous nos amis tout le temps ils
sont même pas dans la scène moi je
trouve ça injus et je trouve qu'elle
sort de récupération et du c'est logique
si on devait cautionner tout ce que
faisait nos amis mais j'imagine moi
Gilles Verdez mon petit frère a vu la
vidéo comme vous
il a vu la vidéo
après c'est pas c'est moi je serai les
mariés je serai en colère contre vous
effectivement raison moi je vous dis à
quelque chose quand même moi ou nous
tous dans Moi non tout ça parce qu'on
est tous garant maintenant c'est plus le
marié c'est tout garant non c'est pour
ça c'est vous cortège moi ce serait
marié donc il est en train de dire que
c'est la faute du cortège pas démarrer
si vous voulez c'est notre faute si vous
voulez
si vous voulez c'est de notre faute mais
pas de mariée la question elle est sur
le sujet vous écoutez ce que je dis oui
je dis c'est le moi je serai le marié je
serai en colère contre vous ok bordel là
c'est vous c'est pas le marié il est pas
au courant vous l'avez dit donc voilà
maintenant je dois dire que il y a des
cultures comme vous l'avez cité tout à
l'heure vous-même des cultures ou le il
y a la naissance le mariage et
l'enterrement qui sont les trois choses
et le divorce aussi le divorce aussi
ce sont trois choses très importantes et
qui sont toujours dans certaines
cultures extrêmement festifs et c'est ça
qu'on voit souvent si vous avec ce
bordel dans les rues investissements
et tout le machin voilà c'est pour ça
que là c'est très spécial ce qui est
arrivé je peux le comprendre mais manque
de peau il y a un problème et donc vous
l'avez compris
vous l'avez compris il nous a fait une
Castaldi on a rien compris non mais
c'est la place c'est la place c'est
normal je te tiens pas rigueur c'est la
place ce qui est comme ça Kelly moi je
pense que l'ambiance elle pue elle
craint je trouve ça nul je trouve ça
zéro comme type de comportement après le
problème c'est que moi je pense aux
mariés moi c'est pour moi c'est c'est le
numéro 1 à qui on doit penser et je
pense sincèrement que le maire a eu
raison d'annuler le mariage ça leur
laissera le temps de changer d'amis
parce que ça pour moi c'est pas des
frères les gens qui se comportent comme
ça tu vois ce que je veux dire moi mes
potes mes frères de chez moi qui se
comportent comme ça mon mariage mais je
change et j'ai réinvite pas tu vois ce
que je veux dire moi je pense en mariage
je vais te dire quelque chose je vais te
dire que et je suis dég
on est là pour ça à la base on est là
pour parler du mari on est chez le
cousin c'est le frère on est directement
impacté bien sûr qu'on pense au mariage
avant quiconque d'autres donc je suis
pas là pour justifier l'effet tu me dis
que en gros avec moi au final c'est
mieux comme ça on change d'ambiance on
change d'atmosphère ça serait mieux avec
de nouvelles personnes qui respecteront
les mariés c'est comme si tu disais que
tout le monde en fait voulait ça même
dans ceux qui sont présents sur la vidéo
pourquoi parce qu'il y en a beaucoup qui
viennent pour essayer justement que ça
se passe pas
dont on parle pas c'est à dire que ce
mais en fait ceux qui ceux qui sont
impactés directement et ceux qui
s'aiment pour eux donne rendez-vous à la
personne le lendemain
et donne rendez-vous le lendemain à la
personne mais là c'est les mariés
tranquille et je crois qu'il est
d'accord avec moi le frère mais non bah
si mais non mais regarde pas que ça
aurait jamais dû arriver je suis le
premier à dire que ça aurait jamais dû
arriver c'est bon ça là ce qui se passe
là ça n'aurait jamais dû arriver la
violence elle aurait jamais dû à votre
arrivée on est d'accord en fait sur ça
on va parler après tout le monde
non non mais on est d'accord sur le fait
que la violence n'aurait pas dû arriver
on ne voulait pas en arriver là c'est
pas la finalité oui mais c'est ce qui
s'est passé
il y a un moment il faut dire la vérité
vous êtes en train de parler de ça
Raymond juste la façon de vous parler
d'abord en 1 je vais penser au mec qui
s'est fait agresser par plein de gars et
sa gamine de 5 ans et en deux je vais
penser au mariage parce que vous lui
avez comme dit moi je rejoins la ligne
de compte vous lui avez flingué son
mariage parce que la voie publique par
définition c'est public c'est à tout le
monde et quand j'entends culture ça
sous-entend encore que c'est une
certaine culture qui font encore le
bordel et on donne du grain à moudre à
des gens qui en veulent à cette certaine
culture c'est à dire qu'à chaque fois
c'est le bordel l'histoire de la Charte
elle a été signée parce que il y a
plusieurs mariages ou à chaque fois il y
avait des grosses voitures de location
des grosses berlines des mecs en cross
qui faisait des roues arrière et ça
foutait le bordel du coup on a dit faut
des chartes moi je suis entièrement
d'accord avec le maire qu'il est annulé
ce mariage là c'est une bonne chose
parce qu'on peut pas dire aux gens
foutez le bordel tabasser des gens parce
qu'ils veulent simplement passer dans
une rue on va fêter quand même votre
mariage vous avez [__] le mariage de
votre pote de ton mon frère ils ont
flingué le mariage avec des
comportements comme ça c'est une fois
dans l'année c'est un jour de fête c'est
une fois dans la vie normalement même le
jour de l'année c'est une fois dans la
vie
une
fois
dans la démarche parce que le mec il a
tout préparé des salles il a loué des
traiteurs il a loué des voitures ils ont
posé des cautions les mecs là ils en ont
rien à [__] ils sont venus ils ont
tapé un mec sans rentrer chez eux c'est
ton petit frère qui a tout pris aussi ah
oui mais peut-être que j'ai faux mais là
où il faut c'est qu'on bloque pas la
voie publique et là où ta faute c'est
qu'on tombe pas sur un mec à 4,5 devant
une petite fille alors j'ai peut-être
faux tu as raison j'ai peut-être faux
sur ce coup là où est-ce que tu as faux
parce que dans la façon dont tu parles
c'est comme si ça avait été fait
gratuitement et c'est ce qu'on entend en
fait tu es en train de dire ça comme si
la personne on la VA attrapé au hasard
et qu'on avait tabassé il y a des faits
j'ai une cautionne pas ce qui s'est
passé
le mec pour passer est-ce que ça
justifie le fait qu'il va y passer qu'il
aille foncé dans la voiture ou qu'il
aille ici parce que c'est ça que vous
montre vous avez des extraits de la
vidéo merci en fait vous n'avez pas le
contenu du départ à la fois
c'était fait un bon enterrement c'est ce
que j'explique mais vous l'avoir raison
pour partir avec de l'émission en ayant
peut-être raison pour vous en tout cas
mais les faits sont là il y a deux
auteurs interpellés et on a que deux et
on voit que sur la vidéo il y a pas que
deux personnes qui frappent
le jour où les gens comprendront que le
93 c'est pas une zone de non-droit vous
savez nous la solution serait facile à
vous faites une déclaration de
manifestation mais c'est pas le cas
quand vous faites une déclaration de
manifestation vous avez un vous avez un
dispositif de sécurité comme l'a dit
madame vous avez des droits et des
devoirs et des obligations également et
là il y a rien en fait et là vous êtes
en train de nous expliquer qu'en fait
c'est de sa faute fallait pas qu'il
rentre dans sa rue voilà juste à un
moment vous voyez c'est ça le problème
et nous en tout cas en tant que
pollution on aimerait avoir on aurait pu
arriver plus vite on aurait peut-être pu
éviter ça mais aujourd'hui dans le 93
c'est un des le département le plus
criminogène de France on peut plus faire
face à ça parce que vous imaginez chaque
si on devait suivre chaque cortège de
sortir un quartier comme vous dites ou
comme vous le pensez vous certaines
cultures là je suis pas d'accord mais tu
parlais qu'en tant que policiers mais
voilà en fait nous on n'a pas les moyens
en tant que policiers on n'a pas assez
d'effectifs pour pour arriver à
combattre ça c'est dommage qu'il faut
qu'il y ait une vidéo pour que les gens
prennent conscience c'est dommage qu'il
faut qu'il y ait un maire qui dise stop
voilà le faire se marier
de la culture je parlais surtout en fait
l'environnement social que ce soit des
blancs des Arabes des Noirs peu importe
tous les gens là que vous voyez là il y
a beaucoup de danse mariage aussi il y a
beaucoup de Français 100% français c'est
en fait c'est un environnement social
c'est ça et vous êtes en train de
stigmatiser cet environnement là parce
que non mais tout le monde en fait vous
êtes en train de dire que c'est là vous
les qualifiés donc dans les médias comme
voyou racaille pourquoi parce qu'il
s'est passé ça mais ça cette vidéo là
victimiser juste tu te victimes pas
forcément de vous parle pas forcément de
vous ici les blancs sont 100% français
comme les noirs sont 100% français en
plus on parle des origines on peut être
français d'origine africaine on peut
être français on a des origines la
nationalité c'est pas les origines
maintenant ce que je veux dire c'est que
même le débat d'avoir dit culture c'est
pas vraiment ce qui est ce que j'avais
dans la tête bien surtout parler en fait
l'environnement social dans lequel on
est voilà on a l'habitude de faire la
fête comme ça un peu ça peut déranger
des fois mais en l'occurrence c'est pas
méchant on est pas en train de viser qui
que ce soit non on n'est pas en train de
viser ce soir mais on n'est pas en train
de tirer des mortiers sur les gens mais
ça change quoi vos
interdits
déjà on avait reçu aussi que des
personnes t'es pas sur BMW qui tirait
des coups de maîtresse c'est des balles
blancs ça change quoi l'intention
qu'elle soit bonne ou pas la personne
que dans la rue la vieille dame qui a
peur et qui se met au sol elle connaît
pas vos intentions on vous connaît pas
nous quand on voit quand on voit ça on
connaît pas vos intentions et pardon on
s'en fout juste c'est la voie publique
et même si ce que tu m'aidais pendant la
pub je te crois tu m'as dit c'est lui
qui vous a insulté le premier peu
importe vous êtes un cortège voilà vous
êtes un cortège de mariée vous étiez là
vous étiez nombreux et t'insulte tu
passes à autre chose
non c'est ce que je disais c'est un peu
une sorte de malheureusement si on suit
un peu le monsieur c'est que bon on voit
beaucoup de faits divers et une sorte de
banalisation de la violence même vous il
vous dit voilà je comprends pas mais
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui Épinay-sur-Seine
c'est une zone de non-droit d'après ce
que vous me dites c'est à dire que les
gens bah si puisque on a le droit de
bloquer les rues on avait les moyens de
pouvoir faire la fête avec une passe
privée peut-être de mettre 100000 euros
tout le monde aimerait avoir les moyens
des autorisations tout le monde aimerait
avoir les moyens c'est qu'avec ce genre
de cas et ben on s'arrête jamais vous
voyez ce que je veux dire fais avec ce
qu'on a essayé de faire la fête de notre
côté vous me gênez quand même parce que
vous vous dites globalement que votre
que vos collègues ont mal fait leur
boulot alors qu'ils ont été exemplaires
avec les caméras de surveillance ils ont
arrêté deux personnes parce que
non mais il y a que deux personnes non
il y a que deux personnes qui ont été
arrêtées Cyril les policiers ont bien
bossé avec les camarades surveillance et
la Reda vous élargissez en disant
regardez il y a de la violence partout
c'est presque une zone de l'endroit etc
maintenant mais je suis désolé je suis
désolé on est responsable que de ce
qu'on fait deux personnes inadmissibles
sont arrêtées seront jugés j'espère que
tes conneries je vous donne envie
n'importe quoi il est en train de
marketing
c'est l'endroit le plus criminogène
il y a pas que de personnes ainsi va sur
Youtube regarde les vidéos de mariage
regarde les vidéos de mariage tu vas
voir qu'à chaque fois qu'est-ce qu'on
fait pour arrêter ça qu'est-ce qu'on
fait pour arrêter comme dit Mathieu les
mecs qui tirent les roues les mecs en
roue arrière sur l'autoroute qui bloque
les auto avec des voitures de location
avec qu'est-ce qu'on fait
que j'ai de la voie publique c'est la
voie publique on vit ensemble Daniel on
nique pas le mariage du mec qui se marie
moi je vois juste que ces paroles contre
parole monsieur a dit quand même que il
y avait quelqu'un qui avait voulu le
sortir avec en lui disant va te casser
la gueule je ne sais pas si c'est vrai
vous je ne sais pas ce que vos
intentions non plus donc ça c'est
difficile de juger mais sérieusement
vous auriez pu manger des petits fours
et ça va être champagne avec une game en
sachant qu'une gamine a été traumatisée
quand même malgré tout à cause de vous
enfin moi ça me paraît ça me dépasse la
merde encore une fois le mariage n'est
pas sur place madame
dans une ambiance pour boire du
champagne après parce que le maire je
crois qu'il a annulé parce qu'après il y
avait une fête prévue et dans une autre
ville tout proche il a eu peur qu'il y a
eu aucun débordement maintenant regardez
ce que je vais vous dire
on peut lui expliquer sur la vidéo il y
en a qui arrive qui n'ont pas forcément
vu et qui arrive pour essayer de séparer
vous parlez comme si tout le monde
c'était pas non il y a des gens qui ont
été impactés directement ça touche leur
argent eux leur caution à eux ces
gens-là ont peut-être ont pété un plomb
et 200 enfin avec le sur le coup en fait
à chaud même si c'est un petit oui mais
ces gens-là à chaud on réagi cette façon
là ces gens-là chaud est-ce qu'on peut
comprendre qu'un humain quand on vient
du bousiller peut-être 10000 € sur le
coup il réfléchit pas peut-être et on
excuse pas j'ai pas que c'est la
meilleure solution comme je vous ai dit
dans sa voiture
s'il te plaît même si je passe à côté de
toi Mathieu et je t'empêche d'avancer un
feu rouge est-ce que tu vas me rentrer
dedans joue jamais
tu comprends ce que je veux dire merci
Ryan bon on espère surtout que là la
petite va pas j'espère que la victime le
véhicule a été déplacé par nos soins
pour pas que la petite assise
et que le mariage aussi on pense aux
mariés il va pouvoir avoir été avec nous